I love this oh thank you oh my god with
your red hair I'm in love with all of
you I would introduce you but I hear
y'all made out before yes yes yeah I'm
on a TV show just backstage it was weird
guys get a room no but how how do you
remember the kiss either one of you yeah
yeah we it was this show my at a sketch
show and and Jane was on it it was a
very silly sketch called Madison chooses
and she was great and I played two
characters like the bad boy and the
sweet guy and we had fun yeah actually
remember after you made fun of it you
remember like well yeah I mean it was
awkward
people often ask like is it weird to be
an actor and have to like kiss people on
sets yeah and I also I remembered this
but then I was thinking about this story
I remembered making a movie in 2011 I
had to kiss my co-star and another
co-star came up to me after the kiss and
was like I found a raccoon trapped in a
trash can once and that's how you guys
sounded when you were making out I will
not stop talking until you subscribe to
my youtube channel that's right and I
could talk a lot seriously not gonna
stop yep still here not going anywhere I
see you don't walk away from this